a partisan fight in congress over covid
and wearing masks has hit a new level
three democrats who just tested positive
are condemning
republican colleagues who refused to put
masks on when sheltering from the
assault
on the capitol last week the house voted
last night to find members who don't
wear masks on the house floor
our lead national correspondent david
begno has the story david good morning
good morning you know during that vote
to approve the new rule last night more
than 70 members of the house of
representatives voted by proxy meaning
they were
absent not on the house floor and it was
likely due to concerns over coronavirus
one of those congresswoman was bonnie
watson coleman from new jersey
she's 75 she's a cancer survivor and she
believes her republican colleagues are
responsible for her contracting the
coronavirus
and here's why
as rioters attacked the halls of
congress last week representatives were
whisked away
led into the bowels of the capitol and
packed into secure rooms
[Music]
and that is where six republican
representatives were seen
refusing masks even as they crowded
together with
other potentially vulnerable members of
congress members like representative
bonnie watson coleman
a democrat from new jersey she published
this op-ed in the washington post
blaming republicans in congress for
giving her coven
the headline in the washington post
reads i'm 75
i had cancer i got coveted 19 because my
gop
colleagues to dismiss the facts
yeah that's pretty much the truth i
didn't have it when i went down there
and the most interaction
that i had was in the holding room other
representatives in that room have also
tested positive
illinois congressman brad schneider and
washington representative pramila
jayapal
now jayapal was seen in videos from the
incident without a mask on
she says it's because she was instructed
to take it off so she could put on a gas
mask
seen here in this video congresswoman
what would you say
to your colleagues who weren't wearing a
mask that i'm angry with you
that there are to be consequences for
you not wearing your mask
because your right not to wear a mask
does not supersede my right to be
healthy
and safe now some good news the
congresswoman is feeling well
she is at home she says it feels like a
cold right now and hopefully it doesn't
get worse than that
i should tell you my team reached out to
all six of those republican
representatives who refused to wear a
mask
we reached out to them multiple times
and they never responded to tell us why
they did it
there was a comment issued by the office
of marjorie taylor green the
congresswoman from georgia
uh her office in part told cnn and i
want to read it to you
she does not believe healthy americans
should be forced
to muzzle themselves with a mask close
quote
gail i don't know how a mask is a muscle
i was just thinking david well that's
one way you could look at it
you could also look at the other way of
i just want to live i want others around
me to live too
thank you thank you very much david
thank you so much